now the first ship carrying Ukrainian
grain has left the port of Odessa under
an agreement signed last month by Russia
and Ukraine the razoni is a Sierra Leone
flanked vessel carrying more than 26 000
tons of corn the agreement for a safe
passage was brokered by the U.N and
turkey in a bid to avoid a global food
crisis John hendron has been following
developments from the best support
you could see anybody watching this ship
leave there were just regular citizens
taking pictures you have to be very
careful of how you do that because you
can't take a picture of the port here
and the military has been here making
sure that didn't happen but it's been a
long time coming but the rizzoni was the
ship everyone had been waiting for the
first one to course off through wartime
Waters and bring food to a world that
needs it very badly we have seen on ship
tracking devices that there are a few
other tugboats in the port of Odessa but
so far we don't believe that they will
be escorting any ships sounds like that
first ship they're going to want to take
it all the way to Istanbul before they
carry any more that is the latest word
we have we did talk to a captain on a
ship in the nearby Port of chernomorse
where also grand ships will be leaving
that Captain said he was told originally
to leave today on Monday but that there
have been some complications and they're
still filling out paperwork so we're
still waiting for more ships but the
first one has left that will be a test
case and uh if everything goes well with
that ship more ships will come but this
is still an insecure area there was a
Russian strike yesterday and we just
heard a boom a few minutes ago but we
haven't heard the air raid sirens that
usually follow that so we don't know
what that is but I've got someone here
who knows a lot more about what's going
on in Ukraine than I do he's a member of
parliament his name is Alexi gonchirenko
and let me ask you first what is your
reaction to this historic launch of the
ship today
I'm absolutely happy because that is
historical for Odessa that is historical
for Ukraine and that is historical for
the whole world because millions of
people are safe from starvation and food
crisis which was artificially made on
the planet by Vladimir Putin by this
awful blockade of the Black Sea and this
Invasion I can't say it's over but
definitely it's decreasing now and that
is extremely important and like for
example Lebanon is dependent on the
Ukrainian Grain on 80 percent and this
first corn we can still see the ship in
the which is the living is taking the
corn to Lebanon 26 000 tons Egypt is
dependent from uh Ukrainian grain and
together with Russian and 85 percent
just imagine these numbers and all
together in the world 400 million people
are dependent from the calories from
Ukrainian crops so that is extremely
important important moment